Super Bowl is this weekend a lot of us
are certainly just as excited for the
halftime performance as we are for the
big game right here our own Sasha loft
is joining us live from Glendale Arizona
once again this morning with what we can
expect Rihanna shining bright like a
diamond
absolutely John and Heather yeah I'm
pretty excited for the halftime show or
the Rihanna concert as many people are
saying you know a game happening before
and after you might have heard of it at
the Super Bowl I'm here at State Farm
Stadium just two days away from both of
those uh performances now yesterday we
did hear a bit from Rihanna of course
that headliner for the Super Bowl
halftime show along with Chris Stapleton
who is performing the national anthem
now Rihanna did give us a couple teases
of what we might be able to expect for
that performance this is actually her
first time on stage in seven years also
her first time performing since she
became a mom to her eight-month-old son
she said she's trying to figure out how
to fit more than a decade's worth of
music into less than a half an hour
there were no major giveaways about the
song she'll sing but she did reveal a
bit about her thought process
so you're trying to cram
17 years of work into 13 minutes so it's
it's difficult but we you know some
songs we have to lose because of that
and and that's going to be okay but I
think we did a pretty good job at
narrowing it down
so we actually got locked out now
Rihanna says she had 39 different
versions of this before she selected
this final performance that's happening
on Sunday she talked a bit about the
setup and the teardown of that stage
three to four hundred people involved in
that and it's only set to take about
eight minutes which is insanely
impressive to me so lots to look forward
to as we head here into Super Bowl
Sunday hopefully the wind dies down here
I think I brought it with me from Las
Vegas it's kind of blowing us all over
this morning but again we are very
excited as everyone here is as well
reporting live from Glendale this
morning Sasha Loftus 8 news now that is
something shrouded in secrecy especially
with all those people who know oh yes
that's very impressive probably some
India